the Joe Rogan experience such a weird
time right now that I keep thinking of
what what it's gonna be like on the
other end you know instead of just just
living which I've never really do I
never really think what's gonna be like
on the other end I always just do stuff
you know like whether I'm doing a
Netflix special or whether I'm doing
podcasts or doing stand-up I just do
stuff I don't think like oh like do it
like this
one day it'll be that and then maybe
people will like this and maybe though I
just keep doing it but now I'm like what
is gonna be here like but what is
society gonna be like with no
restaurants what is society gonna be
like with 50% unemployment what is
society gonna be like if that disease
kicks in again and what's gonna survive
so I'm wondering about the future now I
never wonder about the future I was just
kind of do I'm so lucky now I realized
so so lucky that I can do that that I
could just concentrate on the [ __ ] I
enjoy doing and that's the big advantage
of that too is it helps you be good at
that thing because you have less stress
less things you're thinking about more
sleep for everybody but now everybody's
got to be a prepper everybody's got to
be a little paranoid everybody's got to
be a little a little wacked out by this
everybody does even people like you and
I they would want to just blow it off
and they live in the moment
now you can't now you have especially if
you have people you love that are
relying on you like you have to have
food now you have to keep food of your
[ __ ] house fine toilet paper that was
a weird one it is okay why didn't
everyone go crazy for food why everybody
worried about wiping their ass why is
that them the number one thing that
seemed to be the issue or then water I'm
like yeah water makes more sense in
toilet paper water makes a ton of sense
and so does food like dry food bring get
oats right get oatmeal [ __ ] like that
rice stuff that lasts a long ass time
you need pasta you need stuff that you
could just make with a fire and a pan
and some water you need to be able to
just have stuff that'll keep you alive
for X amount of days that's what you
need y'all need toilet paper you need a
rag
sink and there you go you got a clean
[ __ ] tada
you know or get one of them ones that we
got in here squirty up the booty hoses
thing okay whoo they have a new one that
was a sponsor that you can attach to the
back of a toilet it's like it's not
expensive oh yeah yeah what's that
called
your cousin touchy touchy right yeah
what's that cause it's very first off it
$79 yeah so for 80 bucks you get a clean
[ __ ] and you save a million dollars
on toilet paper and it takes it takes
like three minutes to install and it's
the same water that you press your teeth
perfect goes right into the sink after
you clean your [ __ ] no there was on
the reed and that was my favorite thing
to say it's same thing that's cleaning
your butthole warm water one it's only
$30 more Oh splurge yeah focus you're a
hard-ass I see one of them Navy SEAL
type dudes likes to suffer yeah yeah you
could in if you decide to get a more
expensive one you can skip the air
drying one because it just makes it do
the whole plate smell like your [ __ ]
it's disgusting I don't like the
hairdryer I went over this person's
house once and they had a bad day and
inside their bidet was a bar so I was
gonna take a leak there's a bar soap and
a wet rag and I was like that's how I
use it you get in there with that soap
wash the old poop chute and that water
shoots at the bidet is like the most
unorganized ever it's basically if you
fall and slip something happens and you
got like slippery socks on or shoes you
you fall that pipe is going right up
your [ __ ]
that's stupid pipe it's in the middle
fall all the time people died trying to
climb fences do you know that those
spikes on fences kill people every year
you slip on fall and fall on the bidet
and it punctures your [ __ ] like a
robot dick think about what that thing
looks like that that that it looks like
that like the top of a hammer the one we
got it doesn't come out until you hit
the button it's like a robot
that's different that's different but
it's not a bidet I'm talking about a
bidet like a friend no no no no no
that's a bidet seat
these folks it was French it was a
French doctor and his wife we were over
their house they were French and they
had this bidet and it's uh looks like
you know like if you slip like you're
getting your butt hole clean by this
little little [ __ ] pipe that's
sticking straight up with little it
sprays water and you're supposed to get
up in there with soap wash it down
nope that's the way to do it though
better than the way we do it I'll smear
and everything there it is so that one's
a that's a safe one some of them have
protrude rinse used to have one Jesus
yeah I'm trying to find one that sticks
out more alright give up here fine what
did that circle look at that that the
the the the drawing to the left with the
red circle click on that oh wait you
said he's looks small that they're
little maybe someone's a cruel person
that had yeah maybe it's one of those
douche sticks I don't want to date that
porn star she's to have the anal douche
that pole Wow
I was in New York once and I posted on
Instagram the [ __ ] had not one but
two hoses had a hose on either side
didn't get it I didn't get it either
until someone explained to me that some
because it was a very fancy hotel and
some people from other lands prefer to
wash their hand wash their ass rather
with their left hand
it's the lefty style yeah so for you to
ask them to grab a hose on the right
hand side and hose down their [ __ ]
they'll be offended you're not supposed
to do that we were right in you supposed
to do it your left hand
mm-hmm like that right like I'd like a
hose off yeah - and one on each side
like a industrial-strength I see I think
I made a YouTube video or a Instagram
video huh yeah it's um it's a better way
to clean your ass that's for sure like
the way we do it with toilet paper is
really disgust oh it's [ __ ] gross
you're just smushing it around like if
you had that [ __ ] on your eyebrow not
your taint Harris but your eyebrow hairs
how much rubbing there it is one on the
left one on the right what the [ __ ] dude
look at that I like that you try it out
yes
with much shame with their poop juice
everyone man that one that one's for a
big [ __ ] what maybe once for a [ __ ]
and once for an [ __ ] maybe you double
jam write and write hammers to [ __ ] cuz
my birthday has a [ __ ] mode but in a
Nash mode yes girls probably use that
thing it feels good on there but I asked
I'm not ashamed to admit it at warm
water oh yeah what's up on your butt I
guess it's a smaller little thing that I
remembered so they don't think you have
to worry though the bidet there's a
bidet on the other side of the room too
look if if you see there over there
that's a bidet
so there was a bidet see that's what I'm
talking about see that little robot dick
it's sticking up did you see it in the
bidet watch see watch when they turn it
around or when I turn it around whether
after I grab a hold of these two things
I was super confused the other side has
a thing that pokes out in the middle and
that's kind of what I was talking about
and some of them are a little higher
than others but they're these weird
little not that part the other one the
one earlier see
[Applause]